speaking of numbers moving in the wrong
direction covid cases are climbing amid
changes over indoor mask mandates as one
more subvariant works its way across the
nation the average number of infections
is up 51 percent over the past two weeks
while the number of new hospitalizations
is up eight percent over the past week
michael george is here with more on the
uptick michael good morning dana good
morning it's getting tougher and tougher
for people to keep track of whether
masks are mandatory or not that's
because the rules are changing daily and
they vary depending on where you live
take philadelphia health officials
lifted a mask mandate yesterday after
reinstating it just four days before
los angeles facing rising cases will
continue to require masks on mass
transit public transportation hubs that
are indoors
are places where a there's a lot of
mingling either often crowded
and see in some of those settings it's
really hard to have
adequate ventilation and a surge in
boston prompted the health department to
recommend masks once again nationwide
most people live in areas with low
community levels but cases are rising in
36 states driven by the ba2 variant this
is a time
not to be reckless and to wear masks
indoors check up on your vaccination
status as this
current peak or wave starts to decline
then we can breathe a sigh of relief and
feel more comfortable
being going into restaurants and bars
without masks dr peter hotez professor
of pediatrics and molecular virology at
baylor university has the ba2 variant on
a hard watch
the problem with that is it's one of the
most transmissible
covin-19 viruses we know about so ba2 is
more transmissible than omicron which is
more transmissible than delta which is
more transmissible than alpha more
transmissible than the original lineage
and while some celebrated the end of
mandatory masks on airplanes this week
after a federal judge overruled guidance
from public health officials consider
this before boarding a flight the issue
is when you're talking about domestic
air travel when planes are going from
all
parts different parts of the country
you're going to have that mixing of
people from all over the nation and
that's the reason why it made sense to
keep the mass mandates at least on the
airlines
and it's important to note that while
cases and hospitalization rates are
inching higher so far the number of
deaths hasn't risen in fact they're
slightly down that's good news right all
right thank you michael